okay so I Dennis offer
slot talk about whatever I wanted so I'm
going to talk about some work I've been
doing then collect synchronization
generally I'm going to say why I what it
is what I call clock synchronization why
I got interested in it why it turns out
to be a little bit of a challenging
problem it turns out that we all use a
clock synchronization algorithm called
NTP and I'll say why it didn't quite
work for us in this situation
I talked about the clock synchronization
algorithm that we actually came up with
functions and how it works and then talk
a little bit about both future work and
sort of alternatives related work okay
this you know what I say clock
synchronization didn't kind of a
software person you know my mental model
is you got a collection of machines you
know we're looking at machines in our
data and our data center each of them
has something that tries to keep track
of time of day you know you know what
time it is some things and so the
question BR is if you went and we're
able to simultaneously ask each of those
machines what time it is what time would
you get and they're sort of a you know
kind of a famous saying and you know
it's sort of this kind of business a
person with a wristwatch knows what time
it is a person with two watches has no
idea and the reason is you know like of
these things no matter what we do there
are different kind of systems and
different clock domains they read
returned a different value so the reason
we kind of got interested in this you
know Blasi and I was it's kind of a
simple thing we were looking around at
networked machines connected by a
network and we wanted to be able to send
a packet from one machine to the other
and time how long it took and so it's
relatively easy for us to like just
start a stop look at their cut time add
a clock on one machine and then
immediately send the packet out and then
when it arrives at the other machine
look at the time of day clock and get to
time values the problem we ran ran into
if you do something like some take the
receive diamonds up subtract the
transmit time to get the time it took to
send a packet we will repeatedly get
things like been negative numbers and
the problem here is the clocks and those
two machines are so discouraged so we're
trying to think well these machines that
are our data center maybe we could like
make this work by sort of synchronizing
the clocks up this lettuce kind of
understand a little bit how clocks of
are kept and time is kept in a computer
system if you know most systems if you
drill down low enough there's some kind
of crystal oscillator in there that is
it sits there and then oscillates yeah
you know they kind of I guess a little
bit of a miracle of manufacturing
they're able to take these things and
let cut a little quartz crystal such
that it operates out pretty close to
this frequency they want and these
things and so what we do you put one of
these things in you know what it's
supposed to be sort of God frequency
it's running at and you just count the
number of ticks it has and you get a
notion of time out of it and so you know
this is you know how these systems work
and there's two sort of issues one of
which is you know these manufacturers
scared but it's not perfect and that you
know basically if you look at the spec
of these parts you know depending on how
much you pay you know they'll they'll
list them as saying it's accurate and
like six parts per million which you
know in our world means it's accurate to
know like six microseconds in one second
so you know not who not that super
accurate even worse they have figures
like this that show if you vary the
temperature
what happens to the frequency of this
thing curious thing is you know if you
operate near like 25 Celsius with this
particular part you know you basically
would be close to what the manufacturer
frequency but if your temperature varied
from that you're gonna slow down garlis
so I got warmer or colder in there if
you look at the unit's here on the side
these are effect way microseconds you
could end up you know like it the thing
heats up and having the frequency kind
of go south on you and in a hurry and so
one of the things that this has been you
know you we see with our you know clock
sink is this and you start the machine
doing something it has the microphone
stop okay yeah sending out we basically
if you got you know just like we were
looking at clocks on network interface
card you send a bunch of packets out and
your clock frequency change and changes
on you and stuff so this is sort of an
inkling of what you know said oh can go
raw you know what makes this a hard
problem when we started I'm working
we're actually collaborating with a
major cloud provider whose name starts
with G and basically there was a nice
cluster of event you know Vance cluster
they're putting together and we ran some
experiments just looking at a sort of
clocks on their machines and stuff and
they tell us they actually paid extra
for their clocks and they're better than
the average ones and stuff and so big
cluster what this is showing you is the
difference in clock frequency in a clock
drift in my per seconds per second
across all the pairs of machines in
there and you can see it's got a nice
sort of you know distribution but the
tail of it goes out to like 30
microseconds per second and
what it means is that you know if you
just let these things run try to keep
time they're gonna be off pretty quickly
so let's say you're running NTP you know
the NTP spec basically is you know from
an age of the early running over the
internet and stuff and so not wanting to
do lots of traffic it exchanges messages
or of a disaster if you're trying to
actually program to it means you know
with that kind of drift you're in the
hundreds of microseconds up to
milliseconds sort of range you know in
terms of the skew and the clocks between
things Sydney how we decided to take a
look at what this and came up with this
algorithm a couple of things in one of
which was early focused on data centers
we were interested about it and there's
been a long history of people you know
like taking of data centers were started
just using pretty much off-the-shelf
both hardware and software and now you
know slowly we're written you know
everything's been customized for it and
so we decided to take a shot at NTP you
know in this world we basically have a
pretty impressive interconnect they have
these sort of factories in there that
have very you know you know very high
performance you know high bisection
bandwidth and stuff it's also you're
relatively close you know it's not like
the internet you know to basically send
a message it's pretty bound to be how
long it's kind of bounced around that
Network before it comes out the other
end and stuff and so we thought about
sort of you know
and what what can we do and as I
mentioned Balaji with one of the main
instigators hair and his researcher grew
a couple things we sort of decided on
one a which is we've got to adjust the
clocks much more frequently than once a
minute you know like since you know
you're just gonna be dead with the way
their oscillators sort of work the other
thing we did was most of the clock
algorithms just look at you know how far
your clock is off and trying to correct
it we decided we wanted to sort of model
these oscillators we know about they're
sitting there running and their
frequency is drift
you know drifting apart and stuff and so
you know had our algorithm sort of know
about that and so it kind of helps us
and then finally you know being sort of
CS people in are we decided to try to
turn this into a big data problem where
we're gonna collect a lot of information
across the data center and then crunch
on it and figure out what the clocks
should be and then adjust the clocks
with that and so this is pretty
different than you know like most of the
other protocols that tend to look at a
local or pairwise type of thing and you
know we got away with it since we're
working in a data center okay so it
turns out pretty much every clock
synchronization algorithm works about
the same way they send messages between
the machines letting other people know
what time it is and stuff and so you
gonna you're gonna have sort of this
idea we're gonna send a probe message
from one machine to another let's say we
know there's some time we're at time T
here if we're running on machine a here
we can assume the clock is set off by
some amount will call that amount Delta
PA and so with we send to pack it out
it'll get a timestamp on and up ta here
which is T but a plus Delta ta that
message goes from a to Machine B and
then
it's time-stamped when it arrives at be
that and we can say it's time time it's
going to be then real time plus delta-t
B which is the air and B's clock so now
we have the these two values of time so
so our time are the time stamps we're
going to get out of here our TX of a
which is the transmit time for that
probe and then our X of a B which is a
received time of probe B in our system
and a lot of other ones you know it
seems the obvious thing to turn around
and send a message back the other
direction so we do that so we get a
probe that goes back so now we have a TX
be the transmit side of B and Rx a on a
one of the things we were playing around
with was you know how do we actually
time these things yes
from yes and the question was are we
using something like vsts definition of
time and stuff not really we have some
kind of notion of ultimately of you know
how many ticks of an oscillator has had
some level above yeah well yeah there
would be once our big data's done with
it you know might be a floating-point
number but yeah often those community
integer 70 how we actually ended up
playing around with trying to get pretty
accurate times of transmit and times of
receive you know something like NTP you
know it's not a normal program might
like look at a the current time of day
clock and then call a system called a
send a packet out you know that includes
in the transmit time you know all the
time going through the OS stack and
going through the driver and things like
that and that adds a lot of kind of
noise and jitter and the thing we want
to try to do this a little finer and so
one way one thing we did we found a lot
of the modern NICs actually have ability
to timestamp packets when they put them
on the wire actually use this for a
protocol called PPP that I'll talk about
later but if it's useful for us since
you get some something where the NIC is
you know can do a very precise
measurement of win this thing is sort of
launched into the network you can do a
similar thing on the receive where as
soon as it receives things that gets the
timestamp of it so we use that and I'm
in our first version of the protocol it
turns out that if you're your machine
you know
does not support this ability to time
stamp packets Linux will kind of do it
for it in the driver so what it'll do is
when you go to transmit something it'll
read the you know the clock and the
computer and record that for you and it
would receives it as soon as the Linux
gets control it will record that you
know this is called in Linux software
timestamps and the networking thing we
can use that but to give you a feel for
like you turn now you just have the
jitter of a driver running and in
reprocessing and stuff we get it kind of
bumps us up to sort of micro second
level synchronization that's still good
for some of the things they want to do
and you know when we for example try to
run on a cloud that doesn't provide us
that kind of low-level access to the NIC
we can just use that okay so back to
where we are it turns out that if you
send a packet you can think of the
receive time being that when you sent it
plus how long it took to go through the
network so in our you know system we
received it at our xB my and minus Delta
B and the transmit time was up TX a
minus Delta a and then the delay was
basically how long did it take this
packet to go through the network and any
queues and the switches or whatever
happens in network and stuff if you
start just playing around with the math
you can end up getting the Delta B TB
and Delta a on one side of it and
everything else on the other and then
it's pretty safe bet that the network's
not instantaneous
take some amount of positive time to
propagate through the wires and the
switches so you get this relationship
that Delta P B minus delta T a and so
that's the error and the two clocks is
less than the two timestamps that we
subtracted from each other like that so
we have an upper bound if you do the
same math on the return probe you
actually get a lower bound for that
delta T B minus Delta R a so now you
have a bound
you know it's between those two of it
and so if you were to look at this yeah
yeah so that's a good point the question
the question is you you actually read
the clock on the same machine sort of
multiple times and so because you're on
the same clock you'll get some values
and you know a little bit about their
relationships to one another if the
clock is monotonically increasing and
it's dacovian Anna its rate may vary but
it doesn't as it turns out it's not
going to vary dramatically over that
interval right so each of those is
consistent but I thought you were asking
about
yeah it's are you you can't know
anything about the two that one's on
different machines but within the same
machine okay so if we were to look at
this in a graph and so here was a graph
that shows sort of time on the x axis
going from zero to two seconds and this
value of a delta T of B minus delta T a
and so each of these dots represents
points either in the lower green in the
lower bound or blue in the upper bound
and so you see something kind of
interesting happen and you basically see
the Bob this is skew between the two
clocks and so you know when this
two-second intervals started out the
clocks were like 93.3 microseconds apart
and they're offset and after two seconds
you know you look here and the offsets
now up to 96 point six you know and so
that's basically mean these sort of
clocks are running at a different speed
in these two machines and in fact by
looking at this we can figure out that
effectively the slope of this line it's
basically losing one point six five
microseconds per second as it's going on
so when I said we're gonna look at sort
of modeling what's happening with
crystal oscillators and stuff it's this
idea that we basically have both the
offset here or what they're wrong but
also what that clock is doing relative
to the other clocks and the system okay
so it turns out that if we rather than
looking at two seconds we kind of looked
over longer periods of time the idea
that you have a line or slope and stuff
sort of breaks down and this is our
temperature effect coming in you know
over a 60 second in a row things can
heat up and the clock starts going side
so you start thinking these sort of
obviously nonlinear sort of upper and
lower bounds going on and so you know
that you so we basically see this we
know what it happens it turns out that
what we've been able to do is say look
over two-second intervals it appears to
be fairly linear because you know
basically it's a heat that sort of
things happening it doesn't happen
instantly but over longer intervals it's
not so we're gonna sort of start looking
at things over to second intervals and
then make our adjustment decisions based
on that and that way we have can assume
things are linear since that's we're
gonna really using just the slope of it
and also to the slope and but adjust
this every two seconds and it seems to
be working pretty well of treating this
thing as a piecewise linear curve okay
so basically in order for our algorithm
to work what we're going to do is get
this data and what we want to do is find
that red line which is like sort of the
both the offset and the slope of between
these two clocks here and so if we can
find this line we now you know have a
lot of information about what it's
happening with time on that machine so
basically the three things we sort of
figured out was wonder which was when
are we you know use well everybody
uses machine learning for that
especially if you want to get funded for
something you know it's like a basically
you know so we picked out this support
vector machine algorithm which is a sort
of machine learning classifier and we
can use that to run the on the data to
sort of find out we've given all these
probes what's the sort of middle line
between those two sort of upper lower
bounds and as we'll see it turned out it
didn't work as well as we had really
hoped it wasn't like a panacea that you
could just throw the data at it and then
it gave you the right answer in fact it
kind of gave me the wrong answer if you
had too much messiness and the data and
we ended up having some messiness in the
data so we came up with an idea to
filter the Ness messiness alcohol coated
probes and then finally you know where
our big data comes in is once we've
collected all this we're gonna bring it
into a centralized coordinator that can
then look over the entire data center
clocks and do some fine-tuning on our
clock adjustments so here's the problem
we ran into we collect some data we kind
of run the SVM on it and we ended up
getting lines it kind of did something
but if you see all those points in the
middle there those are impossible you
know like basically implies that somehow
the message went faster than it could
propagate through the network and so
there's actually the reasons for this as
though the various ones you know but
basically the mechanisms were using for
time stamping and stuff had some kind of
problems with what we will in a signal
processing people would call that noise
but there was basically just wrong and
so you don't like it so basically we had
stuff in the middle here that shouldn't
be there some of the other things these
wouldn't we have times that take longer
or you can kind of explain
but we're going through a network it
could run into other things there's like
dark packets going around your network
that the network folks they didn't try
to hide from you you can run into and
all you know all these things we're
looking for kind of minimum times but we
see all these other ones so what we get
what we do see here is pretty good we
see this set of there's a whole kind of
thick line of things along the minimum
we just got to get the SVM thing to try
to like you know parse it out for us so
it turns out that if you just read ask
for them and stuff and did this we ended
up getting up sort of our clocks sink
down to a few hundred nanoseconds it was
better than you know the other systems
but not as good as we'd kind of hoped to
do basically the SVM's aren't good for
what you have like errors in your data
it's anyhow how do we sort of figure out
delete these things King the problem and
so we use this idea that some other
people had sort of done in networking is
rather than sending just one probe we
would send to probe packets space by
some fixed amount of time like 10 a
microseconds so now we have this pair of
packets that are going from one machine
to another there's a couple
possibilities that can happen one of
which is if they arrive at the
destination and they're more than 10
microseconds apart something happened
you know basically the tail packet got
delayed more than the front packet so
that's not a good thing for us so we can
basically ignore that case yes the other
possibility is they're sort of pushed
together you can see how this one would
happen is a queue in the network I
the probes there the first packet hits
the queue the second packet hits the
queue and they get like jammed together
and then they show up at the destination
like that we want we want to get rid of
those anyhow since they're not good
minimum measurements for us so we're
gonna drop those as well so the final
one is these things come proximately ten
microseconds apart it's possible that
something bad happened and they arrived
like that but it's much more likely that
they didn't get any kind of bad stuff
happening and they kind of went through
in sort of the minimum time so what this
allowed us to do is basically take this
and then you know filter it so it
dropped almost all of a sort of bad
things when we now run the SVM on it we
get some pretty good bounds if something
that kind of tightly hugs the - sort of
points of you know the maximum you know
upper bound and the lower bound and and
then what we can do is basically get the
SVM to tell us what's right down the
middle of that and now we have the red
line we want for our algorithm yes maybe
it's just my eyes
just knock up enough samples once a
below the Greenline we haven't really
looked at data we'd think it's just sort
of random you know you know I've been
honest Li if the kind of things that
cause that is somehow that queuing
happened yet the coded proof didn't
delete it or something like that since
it's taking a lot longer than it should
I know do you know sorry and I'll Balaji
didn't really have a theory that there's
something going on there seventy how
this worked well basically it allowed us
that like toss out all like 90% of the
bad data and the clock sync was now much
better as a factor of four better than
it was was just the raw SVM okay you
know so baby so what's causing that last
10% of bad data the issue is we're
calling something bad when the both of
the probe
you know the pair of coated probes come
in and they aren't ten microseconds
apart I assume what happens is there's
something that can go wrong and your
network where you delay packets and
still have them both you neither coded
pairs that are still show up ten
microseconds the difference you know you
know the simple case of queuing
typically doesn't have that so you know
it's like it's going to be something
weird happening okay so you know the way
the clock said gah groans work is you
basically probe some other machines and
doing this approach where we had each
server in the in the in the data center
probe K other servers where K was you
know on our high-end system was 20 and
then one gigabyte one was 10 so
something along that lines it turns out
that new regardless of how big your data
center is these numbers are plenty or
plenty or plenty big to make the scheme
work so it doesn't have it's not um it's
not it doesn't scale with K doesn't
scale with the size of the data center
we also sent it up so that every 500
microseconds we would send one of these
coated probes you know out so we're now
sending data out much much more
frequently than NTP did it's still you
know this thing was a 40 gigabit links
in this networks and where was basically
using almost no bandwidth of it of
things but we're sending a lot packets
in this thing so basically what happens
up happening is both sides get all these
timestamps things they can actually
locally you know obviously locally
process the coded pros and drop the
things they weren't and then it actually
can run the PM themselves and so what
happens and we have all the machines now
you know process this data and then it
can report back
you know just effectively the offset and
slope that it found for each pair of
machines at probes and we get a fair
amount of well you know great reduction
in data and distributing out the
workaround and then we ship back a small
amount of data to our coordinator now so
it has for every pair of machines that
are probing each other this offset and
and slope data so here's what the
coordinator does is basically it gets
all the data and it can do this kind of
neat trick if it
if it knows that a probes be it can look
at that and so to say well you know if
if a II think that's clock is 10 it
knows from its offset data that a B's
clock must be 10:15 and then what
happens is B goes probing C and the same
thing happens here is if B is at 10:15 C
must be at 10:05 and then finally when
we wrap back around by the cycle in the
graph basically we we have this thing
where either they add up or they don't
add up and if they don't add up you know
there's some error in there you know
you're basically just you know and and
in fact you know the way the sort of
poke probe gaffe was generated with at
10 to 20 random you know things either
you end up with lots of these cycles and
stuff you can go around and and just say
you get all these things now you know
what we do with that is try to figure
out well where did we mess up we
consider guess we know that somehow
somewhere along that route loop are off
by 10 minutes in this case that we can
guess it's 2 2 and 6 or or something
like negative 10 5 and 15 goodness you
know like pretty much anything but what
we ended up doing was just like a eek
not knowing anything different just an
equally dividing it up saying well we'll
put one third to each you know each of
these and adjustment yes
very much do we ever very liquid long
another question was that we I mentioned
we were using 10 microseconds between it
did we try other values and did it make
any difference 10 microseconds is an
example meaning so we actually sent that
back to back and sometimes we're ten
microseconds blossom down six points
hours we already care whatever the gap
was is taken on transmission times time
we've been played off with spacing
between them cutters almost as a
moderate disease be close now we also
tried you know to does something good
why don't we do Creek you know 3/4 pros
you doing extra work are not really
getting a lot of benefit so this is it
has the field why stop at 10 to 10 ways
provision or something same thing yeah
so summary of the answer is we tried a
bunch of things and didn't seem to have
a big effect like and you know we just
basically sent two packets back-to-back
and you know figure it out what the time
was
okay so yeah so the picture here is you
end up with like overlap things so now
we have like multiple chronic correction
things going on and
so we now get a chance to even further
you know but the more sort of cycles you
have the more you can sort of fine-tune
things and as balázs we pointed out
here's a graph that shows the sort of
errors we were seeing both the mean and
the 99th percentile as we varied K and
so as K started getting you know up
until 10 or so it you know you saw some
improvement but after that it really
didn't get much of a win over over it so
that's why you know we're sort of you
know have that number 10 to 20 you know
that we use yeah anyhow yeah so I have
some you know we've decided to like do
some comparison to NTP and so to try to
make NTP not be so totally unfair of
since it's sending from user level and
stuff we sort of modified it so that it
used the NIC time stamping mechanism to
get its timestamp so we have sort of
accurate things and stuff and so the
what this shows is sort of like
different things if there's no load on
the network you know this is up should
be a good case for everybody since you
send your probes out and they don't not
hit likely to hit anything and so
they'll just go through it in minimum
time we we were getting sort of sync
times around 10 nanoseconds and 99th
percentile of 18 NTP since it doesn't
sync is often doesn't have all the fancy
global and data processing was in the
hundreds of nanoseconds when you start
cranking the load up and stuff and you
know the NTP really goes you know
obviously it's not sending that many
and when they have delays that bad
things happened and so you get really
big numbers for it whereas we do pretty
well even up to eighty and ninety
percent load week and still we were
sending all these packets you know if
you're running in a ninety percent load
we're gonna like have what we call
impure probes that run it and when the
pair runs into but just enough get
through that we're still able to sort of
you know get another SVM to sort of draw
us offset and and slope and even the
clock sinks and it works for us so you
know we sort of did that and then you
know 99th percentile even in April
eighty percent load as there was thirty
two nanoseconds one of the things we've
been kind of impressed with is we could
actually been talking to people with
sort of day table data centers in the
FinTech area on they basically have
these data centers they don't run their
network at very high utilization and
stuff and when they run this clocks and
ever report back like single-digit
nanosecond sort of sinks between the
machines there's no I'm not and I am
they're really pleased about it you know
that so it seems to be doing pretty well
and out in the field
I mean yeah yeah so basically it's
trying to wear you know one way to view
it is we're taking out ton of data and
sort of figuring out what the clock
offset is we can actually you're one of
the things we're ended up getting is
we're getting errors that are rates that
are below this in a clock period that
some of the other machines you know use
since that's so that you know it's like
kind of showing where you know the CS
people are eating the world you know you
basically get you know a whole bunch of
data you know compared to these other
things that are trying to precisely time
packets going through the network we're
gonna and we're kind of trouncing them
so a little bit about what sort of going
on here a wonder which is this is what's
releases just mean events so many years
when you write a distributed algorithm
you never worried about you know or even
thought about the possibility of having
synchronized clocks and stuff so you
know having something like this has been
fun to think about you know what would
you do differently if you had this
common notion of this you know being a
systems person making that decision that
I'm gonna count on a clock syncing and
my data center that's a big one it's a
you know like basically you know if you
want to make sure you absolutely can
always count on it and stuff and if it
clocks in fails your algorithm failed it
means you have to make that thing super
reliable and stuff so it's a scary thing
to do but as a research it's sort of
interesting to see what do you think
figure out what the wind would be if you
decided to actually have this as a
prayer
in your data center when unique it's
assumed a common thing about clocks you
know when we talk to the people at
Google that do time there and stuff I
was really struck you know I think
working in time too long makes you weird
and that's a side but anyhow you know
you ask them what time it is they don't
say what time it is that give you a
confidence interval but I believe the
time is between those two these values
as a software abstraction and that kind
of works really well because you know
you you're asked what time it is and
it'll give you something if they're
clock sync kind of goes on the fritz
they can have the confidence interval to
start to grow based on the maxima sort
of you know it's cue they have and the
whole system continues to work as
opposed to like popping over Deb and so
you know this could be interesting
what they call true time I think it's
probably the right sort of abstraction
where when you asked what time you get
two times you know where it's somewhere
in between there with a very very high
probability
anyhow so what started us doing this is
we're interested in trying to do what's
known as Network tomography where you
basically send packets into the network
and time how long it takes and then try
to infer what's happening in the network
and you know with this clock sync we
were able to do that pretty well where
we could figure out what the queues were
in the switches in the network we could
even figure out the content of the
queues and the switches and stuff you
know this the people that made switches
weren't so impressed as they try to do
that with some kind of embed telemetry
and stuff like that but you know this is
pretty nice we're sitting on the edge
there we don't have this stream of data
coming out of all the switches and we're
still computing the same information and
fix so up you know that that worked out
pretty well the system we called Simon
the other place that's known to work and
we've been playing around
this as well as database consistency you
know the idea of Google spanner which
you know everybody was doing these
databases that had relaxed consistency
models and you know some assumption as
the programmer would deal with like
eventual consistency and stuff and they
decided no we're throw that out the
window will provide scrunches
consistency and you don't have to worry
about what happens if you have in are
inconsistent data spanner one of the
things that it turned out that you know
it's good for this kind of thing is
order its ordering things in a
distributed system if you have a
timestamp service that gives you a time
stats they can get a order of things and
this actually landed you know
our group along with the Nasdaq on the
front page of the New York Times since
it was basically you know they got
really excited about it and stuff and
then what what this would mean to like
these training venues and stuff their
notion of fairness you knows now we can
stamp you know time you know time on
everything that comes in and order them
things with it is that and you know
those other places people have talked
about this thing you know like if you've
ever dug tried to debug a distributed
program and tried to get timestamps from
all the different nodes and they're not
ordered you kind of can't even tell what
sort of happened and it and obviously
you're thinking would benefit from that
so I'm gonna talk a little bit about a
related work here you know like what
what are the alternatives to the parts
we are doing a lot of them involve you
know some kind of specialized hardware
you would do with it you can start with
the same water why do you have these
crap in clocks why don't you have a
clock that doesn't really lose time
very and stuff like that and you know it
turns out for even quartz crystals you
can pay about some more money and buy
one that's a tries to keep itself at the
same temperature and isolate itself from
vibrations and all the other things that
can mess up a quartz crystal and does a
lot better it actually for the ones I
was looking at it didn't seem to fix the
problem here at least if you vary the
temperature a lot it doesn't like drop
off the end of a quadratic curve like
that you know they run corrected ones
where you still going to have problems
with it if you were to able to make
little atomic clocks you know those
things you know to come in at a few
nanoseconds per second sort of you know
stir so you know if you were to sync
them up you could run for a pretty long
time before they kind of went off to the
rails I guess it's still like you know
we were out looking for these things you
can't buy them super cheap it's not
gonna drop replace course crystals any
time soon in the data centers
yeah so that balagia points out that
it's getting a no form factor so it fits
on your motherboard it's going to be a
challenge for atomic clock yeah so yeah
we've you know you know heard talk of
people trying to build I was talking to
a physics professor here claimed that
you could do it you know I know but I
don't know maybe that the practice is
harder than the theory yeah yeah pointed
out that the way people currently use
atomic clocks is you have one of them
and you have you know everybody go and
talk to it again it's a really accurate
time so the networking people decided
they wanted to get in the clock size
business and so there's a protocol a
standard called precision time protocol
PTP the way it works is and we were
seeing part of it already the Knicks
when you go to send a packet out time
stamp and when they receive it the time
stamp it they also have all the switches
sort of set up so when a packet comes in
at times how long it was in the switch
before sending it out and so what the
whole system is a little bit complicated
but it what it can do is get pretty
accurate and measurement of how long it
took for a packet to go from one machine
to another and based on that you can try
to synchronize the clocks on the things
we this one has actually been deployed
pretty widely you'll see a lot of the
vendors have PDP compatible switches and
we've seen them in data centers and
like that especially in FinTech area and
stuff those people are interested in our
stuff so it obviously means that thing
is not perfect for them I think part of
the problem is you know it's it's um
you're trying to measure individual
packets that are going through and get
times it means you have some clock there
that you're reading you know when it
goes into the switch and it comes out
like what is that clock doing you know
in terms of its you know varying in
frequency and stuff like that and then
you're getting one like one sample and
trying to make sort of things of it it
did sort of pales in comparison to this
Big Data approached and we're looking at
and stuff we we did you know like really
like what they have done for the Knicks
and that most all the modern Knicks will
try to participate in PTP by
timestamping packets when they send it
under watch yes yes exactly that's what
the way they yes or they use it in that
configuration they have a command that
you synchronize the clocks and the NIC
and then pull it into the house machine
there's another system that people use
that involved is called pulse per second
PPS this one involves like putting an
antenna out and listening to GPS
satellites and the system involves that
you have the antenna on the roof and
then you have the leads from the antenna
go to your machines devilled splitters
and stuff that goes down and then you
need to know the length of all those
wires you figure it out and then you get
the pulse from the GPS sunlight you got
to know the distance from your antenna
to the GPS satellite and oh yeah it
turns out humidity it goes at different
speeds but depending on like how the
weather and
so you need to try to factor that and it
turns out if you put all those things
together you can get quite accurate time
sync and you know obviously if you want
to do time sync over globally you know
that that is a way you could actually do
it you know the the people that have
deployed that we're kind of unhappy that
you have now if the won't run this
separate Network in your data center
that has to have very precision wires
and stuff like that mentioned costs and
the tens of millions of dollars to do so
they weren't happy about that part
there's another concern the FinTech
people have or anytime you play with
money they worry about people attacking
you and GPS is pretty easy to spoof and
so you know there's there that's not a
good thing for it if they're so you know
it's interesting if you're a physicist
and you wanted to solve this problem you
might just drag a wire between the
different machines and you know how long
the wire is how fast the bits go you
know go over it and just sort of send
things around that way and I guess some
people were doing that at CERN and
figured out FinTech people would be
interested in it's a system called white
rabbit that's based on that sort of idea
of deploying a specialized network that
you then just do time to sync over by
send things around never important
really like low numbers like sub at a
second sort of sync you use in using
this sort of system and stuff she'll be
nice interesting the thing that we like
about what we're doing it's a software
system it doesn't really depend on
having a separate network and stuff like
that on it so in terms of future
directions as I mentioned you know we
did this work and suddenly there was all
these people in the industry
when FinTech and stuff really kind of
clamoring to say can we get this and
stuff and it didn't really make sense
for a university project to do it so
Balaji and its students this founded a
company called tick tock networks as sun
ups offering that up to them and doing
stuff in this area and so that the sort
of exciting stuff you know the research
here we're continuing just sort of look
at sort of implications of having this
or look of going through the distributed
algorithms we know about and saying okay
you have these clocks synchronized this
level what can we do with it and stuff I
mean part of my motivation for doing
this talk was that to throw this out and
if you happen to have some application
you think would be nice if the clocks
were synchronized and I would love to
talk to you and look at you know we got
systems for sort of doing this so please
contact us yes yeah I can you know if
you look at sort of the ugly sort of
security problems we've seen lately at
the root of a lot of them is time you
look at all the kind of Intel's you know
I'm so nightmare with spectre and
meltdown and stuff like that at some
point somebody times something and
discovered something in it so you know
it's not yeah I can see where you know
this even things that might be a scary
thing for scared you know point of view
to have this new capability in the
system yes
yes we don't but people obviously do
that there's actually people that sell
products to FinTech which are just ntp
with that you know you can actually just
set that in the config file tell it that
it goes down to eight seconds or
something like that but you know I'm
just an even the stock release and you
can crank that down even more you know
so yeah it would obviously have been way
worse this year would let it drift for a
minute before correcting how you filter
the stuff that you're getting all this
data and your clock is is going tick
tick tick but maybe as frequency is
changing because the temperature is
changing so the question is how do we
filter out the noise and the samples you
know so we're taking any antenna probes
coming in and what comes out of those
machines is just an offset and slope so
term end you know tremendous reduction
in filtering and stuff so you know any
kind of bad stuff hopefully it was just
sort of wiped out by that mechanism and
stuff so the amount of data were
actually passing around as small it's
like two floating point numbers per pair
of machines yes
little cheaper missions the question is
this allow you to build cheaper missions
you know obviously if somebody said
we're gonna have you by atomic clock for
each motherboard yeah but this would be
a cheaper solution you know that I don't
think people pay very much for the
crystal oscillators these days even the
good ones are are pretty cheap so
concluding slide one of the things that
we've been exciting about it is you know
what does it mean now if you could have
a data center where the clocks are
within say 10 nanoseconds of one another
you know wow wow what can you do you
know obviously you know the the service
where you want it to be able to globally
order things as suddenly available as
time stamping is a service you know this
has been fun to be the software person
especially when the competitors are
either physicists from CERN or
networking people for you know trying to
build source switches and stuff and it's
a good place to be have our total
software and and system and you know
kind of works and you couldn't even
argue and prove things about how it
scales and stuff and then you know the
you know what just conclude you know
we've basically collected a lot of this
probe data used SVM just to try to you
know extract out the information we
needed we took use coated probes to make
sure this SVM's didn't go off the rails
and and then we have these global you
know sort of algorithms that run
so I think that's all I had obviously
there were some questions by Apple happy
to take more
[Applause]